hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 57
hört zu und spricht nach
von bei mit zu mit zu auszeit nach
auszeit nach und gegenüber und gegenüber
immer mit dem dativ immer mit dem dativ
von bei mit zuvor bei mit zu auszeit
nach auszeit nach und gegenüber gut
gegenüber immer mit dem dativ immer mit
dem dativ
das geschenk ist von meiner mutter
ich bin bei
der ärztin
die ärztin
er fährt
ein tag mit dem bus
er fährt jeden tag mit dem bus
ich gehe zum arzt
sie kommen
aus der türkei
sie kommt aus der türkei
seit einem jahr lebt sie in deutschland
nach dem unterricht gehe ich sofort nach
hause
gegenüber
am haus gibt es eine baustelle
gegenüber unserem haus gibt es eine
baustelle
der mann der maskulin
ich spreche mit einem mann
ich spreche mit dem mann
die frau
die frau feminin
ich spreche mit einer frau
ich spreche mit der frau ich spreche mit
der frau das kind das kind
neutral
ich spreche mit einem kind
ich spreche mit dem kind
ich spreche mit dem kind die freunde die
freunde
plural ich spreche mit freunden
ich spreche mit freunden
ich spreche mit den freunden
von
mit zu von bei mit 22
[Applaus]
und gegenüber immer mit dem dativ immer
mit dem dativ
[Musik]